[Music]
um well I guess we're live pom do you do
do people ever introduce you by your
real full name are you just are you are
you pomp at all times um yeah some
people do but uh people get offended if
I go to a conference and I introduce
myself as Anthony and then later they're
like wait you're poomp like who knows
you as Anthony like well that is you
know my name my my parents didn't name
me
that well then then we're going to keep
you as pomp we have pomp here pomp
you've been on the Pod a handful of
times and we've talked about you a
handful of times and we've been on your
pot a handful of times and so it's nice
to have you back congratulations on on
new family member uh and you're here
recently after doing it so we appreciate
that yeah of course just uh just three
dads hanging out on the internet who who
could have guessed I had a good uh joke
that I didn't get to do the other day
when Sam Alman was in the news and then
like it's like Jack Altman comes out and
says something and then Max Altman comes
out and says something then his sister
Annie Altman comes I'm like how many
[__] altans are there there's more
Altman than Panos now what's happening
here because I feel like you have like
brothers coming out the woodwork as well
do you feel that your um you know your
your sibling dominance is threatened in
any way by the Altman right
now I did see people making that joke
and I did Google how many Alman there
are and they are not more alond than
Pomano so we're safe for the
moment what um
I don't even know how to describe you so
I think a lot of our listeners will know
who you are so we don't have to spend
that much time but like you started out
as like kind of a one- trick pony you're
just basically the guy on Twitter who
talked about Bitcoin but now you've
evolved significantly beyond that so
you've got like the pp media Empire but
then you've also like started I don't
even know how many businesses many
though hold on Sam C can we do an
analogy um you know pump going from
Bitcoin laser eyes to real estate and
all kinds of other [__] that he's doing
now is it uh is this Justin Timberlake
from in sync now going solo Justin
Timberlake you know what's the what's
the right analogy here who who has made
such a transition such a life pivot like
this is there anyone that's done this in
Hollywood well here's the thing is uh
it's not really a pivot if you kind of
expand out off of the internet right so
if you think about I started my career
building companies then I went and I
worked at Facebook uh then I started
investing and once I was inves that's
really where kind of the Bitcoin stuff
happened um but even the stuff on the
internet I work directly with you know
Mark Zuckerberg Cheryl Samberg for a
short period of time at Facebook when
they were trying to figure out how do
they grow their audiences on Facebook I
remember early on when [__] Jerry the
Instagram account they were trying to go
from Instagram and figure out what's
their Facebook strategy and so the
reason why I say that is like I don't
know think of like a Kim Kardashian she
goes from like sex tape to reality TV
star to like entrepreneur billionaire to
now like Criminal Justice Reform to I
think she's going to be president of the
United States one day uh and you look at
that and you're like actually the same
thing that makes the sex tape go viral
get you elected to be president today so
like in some ways it's actually the
exact same skill set just you know
packaged up in a different way and with
different Ambitions or or
aspirations you have this really good
job of like brute forcing yourself into
like interesting networking
opportunities so like I feel like I
think Sean is actually better than this
than I am but like I just hang out with
a small crew of just like internet nerds
you've done a really good job of like
meeting actual big shots I think right I
mean like you I don't even know all the
people you know but you were telling me
how you met Julian Robertson who's the
guy who started tiger man or is it tiger
management tiger management but you you
actually like you and then you just you
weren't trying to but you just name
dropped Zuck and I think you've worked
for Snapchat and hung out with uh Evan a
bunch you you've done a really good job
of like meeting all these like crazy
Fascinating People people you know what
I mean yeah I mean I think it's just
like if you're curious person uh other
curious people want to be around those
types of folks and then also uh I
probably more so than many of my friends
say yes to Opportunities um even when
it's not very clear like what is the
purpose for doing this um and so if you
do that enough times like it's just kind
of like shots on goal like you will meet
some of these fascinating or successful
people uh but each one of them is very
different I mean Julian Robertson that
story is um Mark uh mark who uh started
Morgan Creek Capital Management uh we
did a joint venture with him to uh raise
a couple Venture Capital funds and Mark
was this former CIO of the UNCC
endowment back in their late 1990s early
2000s and at that time Julian Robertson
was kind of like in his Heyday right
this was like hedge funds were really
getting off the ground Mark yuso and
UNCC had a really big hand in getting uh
endowments specifically to invest in
these hedge funds uh and Julian
Robertson was on his board so that's how
Mark and Julian met now as Mark would
tell the story uh eventually Julian was
like Hey this kid Chase Coleman who now
runs tiger Global he's leaving I'm gonna
give him some money and he sent him down
to go talk to Mark and Mark gave like
the sixth and seventh million dollar to
Chase Coleman to start tiger Global now
when you look at that you're like okay
Mark yuso and Julian Robertson had known
each other for 20 or 30 years and I
think it was 2019 Mark calls me up one
day and he's like hey Now's the Time
like we're gon to go meet a bunch of
like the legends of Wall Street um and
one of them was Julian Julian was
actually the first stop of the day and
so uh the things I remember from it is
like one you kind of feel like you're
going to meet a legend so like more so
than usual you're like nervous but
excited um and we walk in and he's had
the same office for a number of years uh
he had three secretaries which I thought
first of all is just like that's baller
they all sat outside his office and like
each had different responsibilities so I
was like okay like that's uh that's
different and mind you Julian at this
point is I think like he's definitely in
his 80s and so uh we go into to see him
and he sits down uh kind of in like this
like almost like living room area in his
office and he was the single most
curious Legend of Wall Street I've ever
met he sat with us for an hour and just
kept berading me with questions and and
just trying to actually understand
Bitcoin and blockchain technology and
all these things and you're just like
man this guy does not have to be here
right now he does not have to be doing
this stuff like he is Rich on rich on
rich and he's also like pretty old he's
got to know that like he doesn't have
another 50 years to live but he's
sitting here trying to learn and so
about halfway through the conversation
all of a sudden you could see like the
proverbial like light bulb goes off in
his head and he just sits back in his
couch and looks up at the ceiling and
like starts talking to the ceiling and I
remember being like uh damn am I boring
like did I lose him and he had a
microphone in the ceiling and a speaker
so he could talk directly out to the
three like assistants and he basically
just started asking like hey send so and
so in here like go find this whatever
and I was like this guy like built like
Jarvis in his office like way before
anyone else has this he is absolutely a
legend so it was a really cool
experience uh unfortunately he passed
away but uh but things like that are
just you know once in a lifetime
opportunities that are that are
prequel I can find this client info have
you heard of HubSpot HubSpot is a CRM
platform so it shares its data across
every application every team can stay
align no out of sync spreadsheets or
dueling databases hopspot grow
better and what I know about Julian and
and maybe Sean I don't know if if this
guy if you ever researched this guy so
I'll explain to you but also the
listener but Julian uh he was it it was
called tiger right I mean it was just
tiger management so he started like
tiger which was revolutionary and made
him worth I don't even know how many
billions it was revolutionary why
because what what did they do
differently they made good Investments
or did they actually do something
different he's one of he's one of like
the very first like true hedge funds
right like he he basically was hey I'm
not just going to do like value
investing like I'm I'm a true hedge fund
um and I think that he had like a lot of
what we all look at on the internet
today we're like oh that person is doing
something interesting it was different
he had high conviction and he ended up
being right and so he was able to gather
a lot of assets he was able to drive a
pretty good return um and he did it at a
time where this whole concept of like
hedging or like going long and short
wasn't necessarily the traditional way
of investing and so I don't know if they
actually consider him like the Godfather
of hedge funds but he basically could be
considered that um and then you know the
lore of Julian kind of expanded even
more when a bunch of people who worked
for him left he would seed them and when
he would seed them to get them off the
ground those guys now known as tiger
cubs became very successful tiger Global
probably being the most successful and
so it was like hey he was good as an
investor but he was even better at like
a talent uh um you know kind of
identifier and then seting these people
to create these great firms tiger cubs
is like PayPal Mafia basically of
Finance but it's way bigger so so Google
tiger cubs Finance Wikipedia and you can
just go to the Wikipedia page but they
have sections where it's called tiger
cubs tiger Grand Cubs and tiger great
grand Cubs and it's literally it looks
like if I'm just scrolling through it
looks like a 100 plus names and I guess
it's he he found these guys and he
because of his culture and because of
kind of his Vibe they've all kind of
taken a little bit a little bit of them
and it's some of the biggest names like
including that guy uh what was the guy
named Bill who had like that who like
brought down the economy was it a he
like unplugged he unplugged Wall Street
accidentally he like tripped over the
cord and unplugged it yeah yeah he like
brought down the economy like through a
couple bad bets and then there's like
Chase Coleman who is worth I don't know2
billion dollar who has tiger man who
what was it called I'm getting all the
names wrong tiger uh and then you have
like cotor uh I can't even say these
names these are all names at like juicy
oh wow this guy's prolific man he
started Gucci
C these
are no I know what you're saying it's a
word you've only read you've never had
to say out loud like you know yeah it's
embarrassing and I was like I just
reading this word I don't know what the
hell is this what's her name I have no
idea how do you say this it's the words
that you accelerate through you just say
them really quickly and hope no one
noticed that you mispronounce them what
uh what attributes do you think other
than curiosity did he have that kind of
spread to all these other guys who have
done for example Chase Coleman's an
interesting one because you can't really
like if you Googled Chase Coleman the
guy's worth I think 15 billion something
in that range there's like four pictures
of him on the internet uh like what and
so these like mysterious guys are always
they're always fascinating what
attributes do you think some of these
people have that started with Julian
yeah so obviously I met Julian there's a
bunch of other folks that I've met over
the years uh that would kind of fall
similar to Julian and usually it is not
uh unfortunately in a situation where
I'm like hey I just want to learn from
you you're usually going to like ask
them for something whether it's for
money for an introduction or whatever so
like the power Dynamic is definitely off
and it'd be weird to like sit there like
hey by the way now that the pitch is
over like let me Grill you for 30
minutes um but in those conversations
what you basically find is like they're
all very very curious two is like these
guys just have like brass balls right
like I don't even know how to describe
it other than that they are willing to
just make insane bets at times when
other people are not you know another
person that maybe doesn't get the same
fame or recognition as Julian but I put
up there as one of the best investors
over the last 50 years is Bill Miller
and you know Bill in the late 90s people
were giving him [__] because he said he
was a value investor but he started to
buy tech stocks and so obviously Tech
exploded he was outperforming everybody
uh there's a book that I recently read
where he was the only investor to
outperform the S&P 500 for 10 years
straight uh in the 90s and so everyone
was like you're not a real value
investor and like first of all like it's
stupid to be like oh you don't you're
you're results don't count because like
you didn't actually do it the way you
said you were going to do it um but
Amazon was one of his big bets and so
Amazon crashes like 90% in the dotcom
crash bill just backs up the truck and
buys more and I think at one point he
was the single largest outside
shareholder of Amazon and owned like
15% and so you look at that you're like
okay one like you have to like find
Amazon two then you have to like not get
scared when it drops like 80 90% And
then three is even if you're not scared
you then have to like hold your nose and
put way more money in to buy all of this
extra like equity and so I think that is
a common theme it's just like conviction
and and like the ability to just bet
over and over again regardless of what's
happening and then the last one is like
these dudes are junkies man they're
obsessed I almost think of it like a
kind of a gym rat they not only are
curious but like they do the work and so
in that book about Bill Miller they talk
about he uh was in Baltimore and he had
uh seats behind a home plate for the
Baltimore Orioles and heed used to bring
research reports and read them in the
stands in between Innings and it's just
like like okay nerd right like like
that's insane but also like that's why
you end up owning 15% of Amazon is
because like you did the work it doesn't
happen by accident and so I think that
like that's just a great example of all
of these folks who've been super
successful those are common themes that
they all share that's intimidating I
think right like to hear the story it's
like
what when I hear that I get I my re by
there's no more intimidated phrase then
that's intimidating I think
right I'm scared right guys um no you're
right and also I think the hard part is
is the the line between genius and idiot
is so so thin it's like oh am I Bill
Miller backing up the truck uh you know
when Amazon crashed 90% or am I just a
[__] idiot putting all my money into
a loser that like is showing it's a
loser right now and you know that uh you
know the history of is told years later
and so I think that's the the hard part
is you have to have not just conviction
in the investment you have to have
conviction in yourself that I despite
the market conditions despite the
current results right now am able to
correctly differentiate between a winner
and a loser um if you don't have that
conviction in yourself you can't even
make you can't even have the conviction
in an investment to pull that off yeah
you're basically saying I'm smarter than
everyone else right like everyone else
is selling this thing yeah and I'm going
to go buy it and like I mean again
that's why they call them you know kind
of like the Masters of the Universe in
the hedge fund world is like the people
who end up making a lot of money they
actually seem to be smarter than
everyone else now how many of those are
there well there's way less than the
number of people who claim to be you
know those Masters of the Universe and
that's I think Sean like the difference
between the fools and the Geniuses well
I'll tell a story that's that's like
that my uh my friend was in he's in real
estate and he was around he was making
his fortune early Fortune he was like in
his mid 20s um 2006 2007 and then 2008
happens and you know he's gone from zero
to you know $25 million in like two
three years thinks he's you know super
smart and 2008 happens and he described
it later he's like I he's like oh there
was like a tunnel and uh everyone was
running out like there was a fire on the
other side of the tunnel and um they
were running out and they were like here
take this and I was like wow they're
just giving me this this is amazing this
is way like this price is fantastic
fting is that I just kept marching
forward and everybody else was running
away screaming fire and handing me their
their assets on the way out and um yeah
it turns out I should have ran away from
the fire because he lost everything in
that 08 crash now it's that same you
know that same feeling would be there at
the dot crash everybody's yelling fire
running away selling things for pennies
on the dollar and you know the
difference I think ultimately comes down
to a do you uh can you can you tell
yourself why you were buying something
when everybody else is selling do you
have a belief in this right like um you
know I heard somebody say once I had
somebody else who made a fortune during
the dot crash and she goes um she goes
yeah it was amazing everything was on
sale it was Black Friday everything was
80% off I couldn't believe it the best
companies in the world were 80% off and
I don't know if they were going to
return back to where they were then but
I just knew these are still the best
companies in the world and uh you know
they're now 80% off and and so you know
I think that there's there's you hear
stories on both sides and I think you
got to be careful that uh you know you
don't want to be the guy running into
the fire and how do you differentiate I
think you have to have like some ground
truth that you believe that uh that you
you're willing to stand on you're
willing to lose on you're willing to
look back and say uh I'm okay if I'm
wrong on this I'm willing to lose the
money I lost if I if it turns out that
this this idea was incorrect but when
you guys hear those stories is this like
one of those things where you're
watching a UFC fight and you're a little
drunk and you're like you know I think I
could maybe get a lucky punch and and
compete you know what I mean or do you
guys hear this and you're like I'm just
not in the same league or I don't even
want to be do you know what I mean like
do do you what's your reaction when you
hear the
stories I mean I think it just depends
on like this quotequote circle of
competence right you know if you look
back there's only one time in my life
where I've had the conviction felt like
I did the work and like really backed up
the truck and that was the Bitcoin stuff
and Bitcoin had gone from a th000 to
20,000 in uh 2017 it crashed down to
like 3,200 bucks
and I went on National Television I was
like basically you guys are idiots like
this thing is going to come flying back
we're buying you know blah blah blah
whatever uh we actually one of my
favorite memories that's kind of gotten
like lost in uh in the internet archives
is we issued a million-dollar bet to
anyone on Wall Street and we were like
we'll take Bitcoin you take any other
asset like just pick anything over the
next 10 years if you beat us like you
get a million bucks if Bitcoin op
performance we get a million bucks and
no one took it and so at some point
you're just like okay that's enough of a
sign that like people may not have
conviction but they also like know the
person not to bet against and I think
like that's something in UFC is like you
may look at like a UFC card and you're
like okay I think I know who's gonna win
like these five you know matches but
that one match I think I know who's
gonna win but I'm not gonna bet against
the other person so I'm G like sit that
one out I feel like uh a lot of times
there's that level of conviction across
the market and so Amazon you know people
knew it was like a pretty good company
but no one had the conviction to buy
same thing with Bitcoin when it crashed
like everyone was like I think this is
interesting but like I don't have the
conviction to buy so really it's less of
a leap sometimes than than people
realize um but again I've been doing
this now for a decade there's one time I
can think of that I was like oh yeah I
think I actually know something everyone
else doesn't any other time I've even
tried to think that way I'm like I'm
probably gonna lose all my money I
should just you know sit sit down yeah
yeah I think that's a good point you
have to identify that these things
shouldn't be like once every month you
have this this Grand new conviction bet
it's like maybe once in a decade that
you you you see something that that is
so nonconsensus but you believe in um
it's also hilarious did anybody consider
taking you up on that deal where they
just like uh somebody walked into tiger
they're like uh sir um Tony Pompano has
has offered a million dooll bet and
they're like I don't know Tony uh I'm
out on that did anybody even like did it
register like what what happened you
want to know like CNBC wrote an article
about it like it it was like it was
definitely out there right but here's
the funny part about the whole thing the
people who were like even considering it
were like all the like fools that just
wanted like media coverage so they were
like trying to come up with these like
weird uh um you know aspects of the deal
like okay I'll take your bet but we have
to take the return divided by two times
it by like the number of times I jump on
my head you know and then also I get a
multiply and we're just like dude you're
way too smart for us obviously like we
just want to straight up bet uh if
you're interested in that let us know
yeah also they could have perfectly
hedged that bet I think um if they just
bought Bitcoin in addition to making the
BET right so like yeah I like to think
we issued the BET before the smart
people started paying attention so like
yeah we were good or somebody would have
figured out how to definitely beat us on
were you inspired by the Warren Buffett
million dooll S&P 500 bet is that the is
that what where you took of course I
think that that was one of the smartest
things that he's done like buff
Buffett's interesting because uh a lot
of the advice that he gives I think is
you know pretty solid you know circle of
competence being one um you know uh kind
of value investing like like all these
things that were kind of talking about
here uh I I think uh very much draws
back to Buffett and then obviously
Graham and Dodd and all these guys but
uh he also is like a master marketer
like Warren Buffett was the original
Finance influencer right and I've joked
a million times that if he was today
Buffett in his 30s he'd have a substack
a Twitter account a podcast he'd be
streaming on Tik Tok like doing all this
stuff um and so he understood how to
like Leverage the tools he had at the
time with the media and so he didn't
need to do it but a way to really
continue to to drive like the lore of
Warren Buffett is like issue the BET and
say no hedge fund manager can beat the
S&P over like a decade or whatever we
just talked about in the 90s only Bill
Miller did it right so it's very hard
there was like a period where I remember
I was like beating myself up even over
this podcast where I was like am I gonna
be a content creator or or am I gonna be
a businessman who actually does the damn
thing and I started reading you know I
read a lot of biog biographies and I
actually started thinking about it
differently and you realize that a lot
of these great people whether in
business or not they actually had
newsletters and they like I remember um
what's the guy's name uh chamath chamath
like recently came out with like a
newsletter and I remember thinking like
why the hell does this guy need to do
this why is he doing this paid
newsletter but then uh like Warren
Buffett his annual letters were
basically newsletters I mean he he wrote
them as such and then like I remember
reading about like Ben Franklin Ben
Franklin had a newspaper and he actually
wrote constantly about this I'm reading
about George Washington George
Washington constantly wrote editorials
or Bill Amman does this you know where
he he's like he uses Twitter now but
before that he had some other things and
I remember thinking like no actually
like some of these greats who are great
business people also are content
producers uh you know maybe they're not
that's not their income Source but they
they really are like wonderful content
people you know what I'm talking about
well I I like how you just used content
producer content producer is is nice
that's that's better than content
creator which is better than influencer
actually I think that's all that we need
guys is like you just laid out you're
like do I want to be a content creator
like an influencer or a businessman and
I think we actually just need to be
content man like I think we need to like
we just need to level up the phrase so
that we don't sound like little [__]
when we uh like oh I'm I'm a I'm a
content creator who tweets all day it's
like no no no you're a businessman I'm a
Content man we're just couple couple of
men couple of producers well I remember
one time we had this guest on and Sean
asked this particular guest this
particular guest created courses and
Shawn said something where Shawn goes
you know I create courses too and
sometimes I feel like a fraud because if
I'm so good at this instead of teaching
it I should just go and do it and I
thought that was a really good question
and this question really offended this
person but Sean you didn't mean it to
offend this person and and so I wasn't I
didn't think that they should have been
upset but I also have that same like I'm
like well that's am I a fraud but then
you start thinking about it well you
know Warren Buffett actually t a Dale
Carnegie course he actually also taught
a finance course I forget at which
university uh but it's actually common
that some of these people are teaching
are creating and that has kind of helped
me like feel like less you know like
less embarrassed sometimes about what I
do I I think that you can go through
tons of entrepreneurs you can go through
tons of uh you know kind of financial
managers uh this is very very common and
there's a question of if you can't teach
it do you actually understand understand
it right like like it's almost like a
flip side to it but if you really kind
of just zoom out you're like okay what
is all this content stuff I've been
there right people would be like oh uh
he has a podcast and I used to be like
cringe it was like somebody like stabbed
me in the stomach and twisted it when
they would introduce me that way right
and I'm like you are disrespecting all
this other work that I did to say that I
have a podcast like yes I have a podcast
but also like I wear shoes are you g to
introduce me as like oh Pop Weare shoes
and so I remember uh kind of going back
and like thinking about like dude it's
it's it's it's like calling um milk cat
food you know what I
mean cat food yeah it's like that's not
totally
fair so but but what what you eventually
realize is like it's just marketing
right at the end of the day like it
really is just marketing and uh whether
it's Twitter whether it's podcast
whatever the people who tend to be good
at it don't think of it and like sit
down and like create a marketing
calendar like I don't know they're like
taking a poop and they pull out their
phone they start tweeting like random
things and like they go viral right
at the end of the day it's just
marketing and so in some weird way uh
maybe we all shouldn't like be ashamed
or cringe when people say that stuff
like if you're better known for how good
you are at marketing like maybe that's
actually telling you something right and
so I think it's uh we all have that as
almost like a uh something that eats at
us or it's like an insecurity but
whatever who cares like if they could do
it they'd do it themselves yeah to
clarify Sam I never said fraud fraud
means one thing I said I feel like a
little [__] when I do courses and
there's a big difference fraud means
you're misrepresenting yourself a little
[__] means you're representing yourself
as a little [__] and and you have to
ask yourself is that accurate or is that
not accurate and um yeah that's how I
felt sometimes I felt like a little
[__] for for doing courses when I like
should should I be doing something else
with my time this is I like to teach but
uh but maybe maybe that's like you know
not the best use of time sorry I I
paraphrased that incorrectly I was
trying to I I I actually think I made
you sound better but you know be honest
I'd rather be honest okay pomp you
brought some ideas for us you know that
this is the idea podcast um you brought
some ideas let's rattle them off so uh
start with number one what ideas and
Trends or opportunities do you see right
now in the market yeah so this uh this
first one is one that we're actually
doing um so I've thought a lot about it
housing affordability is the worst
that's been in uh this Century um we
continue to see people are worried like
hey I want to buy a house should I rent
should I buy what are interest rates
going to do all these different things
but there's no dominant voice in terms
of news commentary and data um and so we
started a company called resi club uh
the idea really in the beginning is just
go educate people about what is
happening and so uh I'm not an expert on
residential real estate uh I don't know
that many other experts on residential
real estate um so we were able to
partner up with a gentleman named Lance
Lambert uh Lance was the real estate
editor at Fortune Magazine so he's like
quotequote legit right's got 75,000
followers on Twitter a lot of people in
the industry all follow him and we
basically just said to him like look man
we want to go build the dominant
platform in residential real estate
coverage why don't we do it together we
know how to scale things we know how to
grow this stuff and monetize you know
how the content you are the expert um
and so let's partner up and so we've
gone ahead we've got started it's about
two months old um and you know I love
these types of businesses because they
kind of look stupid almost in the
beginning they're like oh you guys just
like created a newsletter like yeah
that's exactly what we did and then it
turns into like a media and then it
turns into a data product and then like
I don't know 10 years from now are we
going to have the information where we
can go and Seed like you know General
Contractors and different markets to
actually build affordable housing like
maybe and so you start with this small
little thing that you can build
profitably and you don't have to raise
money or or kind of do anything where
there's these you know huge expectations
but as you grow the business you can
increase your ambition over time and so
I think a lot of people start with like
massive ambition like let's go to Mars
and sure there are some companies where
that definitely Mak sense but for
businesses like this it's just like hey
there's a problem and around housing
affordability a lot of people aren't
talking about it we should have more
people talking about it and then we'll
figure out how big it can get and how
ambitious we can be over time but we
kind of earn the right to go do that and
so that's what we're doing how much did
you fund it
with um way less than people would think
uh we were profitable within the first
month uh and so we actually wouldn't
have even need to put money into the
bank account but I think we put $100,000
uh to get started and never touched it
because basically you know within the
first week we were profit and the market
for this is is it Brokers real estate
agents that want to pay for this or you
look at investors or is it the average
person who might be you know on Zillow
looking for a home yeah so the beauty of
residential real estate is it's the
largest asset class in the world but
none of us who are like oh we're so
smart we're like business people we're
Finance people we have podcasts we never
think about residential real estate as
like the largest asset class in the
world we're like oh stocks or crypto or
bonds or whatever and so what you end up
getting is it's a very Niche thing in
that it's residential real estate but
it's a very big thing in that it's the
largest asset class in the world and so
what that involves is home builders it
involves real estate agents it involves
people who want to buy or sell homes it
involves uh people who are doing
mortgages like lenders Etc so there's a
huge uh kind of ecosystem of folks who
all need to be aware of what's happening
in this industry and so it's one of
these great businesses where it's n it's
like small and specific but also large
and Broad at the same time and I think
you're doing it why so I'm looking at
your pay wall and you're saying that um
like basically you get access to a
Regional Housing tracker data like some
type of data set I think that's
smart who is was it just Lance because
it looks like Lance is doing all of the
writing is he also somehow aggregating
all this data as well so Lance is uh
think of him as like the editor-in-chief
like like this guy is lights out right
and so as soon as he was like interested
I was like oh I'm what do we need to do
how do we like run through brick walls
to like get to work with you um so it's
very much like go find partners that you
like look up to and want to learn from
Etc um and he does all of the content
today eventually there will be an entire
team but I think one of the big lessons
that I've learned over the last you know
five or six years of kind of like
playing on the internet and building
these businesses is you just don't need
that much and yes we have an advantage
I've got a big audience right Lance's
been doing this for a long time and and
really understands how to create content
and kind of write articles and and
interview people Etc but at the end of
the day we've now created multiple
businesses like this where we start with
like two or three people and you can run
for six or 12 months and get them
profitable with serious cash flow and
then you start to hire a team salese
other editorial folks Etc can I give you
a critique yeah I think this is awesome
I love the real deal uh which is the a
real estate blog your your premium Pro
Plan is $150 a year that is so stupid
man why aren't you charging way more
it's so hard to do stuff on $150 a year
yeah we we eventually like for for sure
we'll increase the price but if you
think about um a lot of times like even
uh I'll give you another example so
Barry at times is a uh kind of daily
news for Tech business and finance um
and started as an email and when you're
building these businesses you basically
have a choice you can like have a high
CPM and be okay with not selling out
100% of the ads sometimes or you can
have a lower CPM and just sell out the
ads I tend to always go for like let's
sell out all of the ad inventory and
build the muscle of being able to do it
and you can always raise prices later
same thing here with the subscription
for resi Club is starting at 150 bucks
it's like if you're interested in this
and we're actually creating something
valuable there is zero friction for you
paying 150 bucks a year over time we
will increase the price but that's much
better and gives us a better signal than
let's say we came out with like a, a
year and people are like man this is
valuable but it's not worth ,000 at
least now we know okay we have something
that people want it's helpful to them
they're not churning and now we got to
go and do price Discovery over the next
12 months or so we'll figure out what
that price point is um but I'd rather
start with a lower price make sure we've
got the right product and then raise
prices later I like this idea a lot I
think it's a really good idea this is
like A50 to100 million dollar win
bootstrapped I think it's gonna be great
uh you know maybe more but like I think
that's a very realistic outcome from
this but I got to ask you you know it's
interesting to see ideas when you're at
the end of the idea maze meaning like
you figure out like oh this is the
opportunity we should go with you're a
guy who's got a thousand different
opportunities thousand different ideas
of what you could go do can you walk me
through the idea maze how did you land
at this and like what were the kind of
like other paths that you considered and
you know like for example this is
residential why not commercial should it
even be real estate or should it be
Finance because actually you have a good
foothold of finance and I'm sure we
haven't talked about this but I am sure
that there was a little bit of a walk
down in idea maze looking for oh wait
what is the real opportunity here and
then it all sorts starts to come
together you get the right operator you
figure out the right idea the right yeah
then you go for it 100% so uh this one's
actually a great one to talk about this
because we actually uh I would call it
like a false start we had partnered with
somebody else who they were not in
residential real estate the way that
they cut the market was by geography and
so they were very focused on South
Florida and so it was like okay we think
that there's a massive business to build
uh that content first that eventually
leads to kind of data products that is
in the uh real estate market and when we
got started we didn't know a lot of
people right and so I went around I
talked to a couple people I found
someone I said hey they do really good
work uh it was a person I really enjoyed
kind of working with and and talking to
on a day-to-day basis and so we got
started but it was very much like small
geography all about South Florida and
then the idea was like We'll go to like
Tampa and then we'll go to like Orlando
and then we'll go to Atlanta and then
we'll like just go through these
geographies and it didn't work for a
whole bunch of different reasons uh
probably some of it was our fault some
of it uh was the other person was you
know very focused on like what they
wanted to do in terms of the the content
that they had already been creating and
and uh um so we kind of just were like
hey this isn't that this like explosive
thing the market isn't like pulling this
into existence and so like rather than
bang our heads against the wall for the
next 10 years together like you had a
great thing going before we came along
and try to convince you to do this with
us like why don't you just keep doing
that thing I don't want to like you know
hinder your success and your growth uh
and then we'll like go back to the
drawing board and so that's the second
attempt was with this resi club and so
you're right that like one there's an
idea maze but also uh I think a lot of
people don't realize how often there's
false starts to these businesses um
Nikita beay who is I think friends of
all of ours he's talked about this a
bunch with consumer social ABS he's like
product Market fit is not a single
metric like you just know right it's
like everything's exploding and you
obviously have product Market fit but in
both of the apps tbh and gas that he
launched and eventually sold to Facebook
and then to Discord uh I think he's
publicly described many times he would
launch it it wouldn't hit they would go
back like make a couple changes like
launch it again and sometimes he would
launch like five six seven eight nine 10
times and then eventually there was the
right combination of all these things
that work and so there's two ways to do
entrepreneurship one is like I'm G to
bend the world to my will and like
here's the thing that's going to work
regardless of what the market tells me
I'm going to make it happen uh and then
there's like this iterative approach and
a lot of these things that I work on are
much more iterative uh and so you just
have to be really good at like go 100%
in run the test as perfectly as possible
but be willing to cut bait and try a
different combination of the inputs if
for some reason it's not exploding in
the way that you want it to Sean you got
to tell the Nikita story which one just
just the the this last one this last
thing that he did yeah he was he was
telling us as he was building the app
and launching it over and over again and
renaming it and like what was happen one
time they renamed it to one thing and
then it like took off in the gay Market
he's like all he did was change the name
of the app and it appealed to like you
know only gay people and then he changed
the app name and it went back and it it
CH you know changed how the app was
going um you know he I think he says
something that he's like you know the
most important thing for a consumer
startup is like you uh develop a machine
that will allow you to launch tests like
real like High Fidelity tests of your
product like that is actually your most
important product at the beginning which
I kind of agree with but also kind of
disagree with I think that's a really
good way to do the apps he's trying to
do which are
like it doesn't work if it doesn't have
a k Factor over one right like if it's
not viral his apps literally like don't
work and then this app was like I don't
really care about retention long-term
anything like it was like I'm gonna get
you in it's going to spam invite your
friends and then there's a pay wall and
I need like 2% of people to to buy the
inapp purchase and if under 2% of people
do it this doesn't really like make a
lot of money but if I can get two or
percent or more this thing will make a
few million dollars of profit in the
next 90 days and um you know so that
worked really well for that but if you
go look at how some of the great like
consumer products are built they didn't
do any of that [__] like Pinterest not
like Pinterest was sitting around being
like okay I need to create a system
where I can launch systematically in
high schools over and over again until I
get this correct right and uh you know
Facebook and Snapchat like they did
eventually figure out a way to like roll
out and grow that that they did but they
didn't have this like thousand shots on
goal with different variations trying to
get the virality to be just right like I
like I think what Nikita is doing is
awesome because it's such a different
game than one anybody else really was
playing however
you know his advice is basically like
how to build a virus not how to create
the next like you know social network
and I think people think of him as the
genius consumer social network guy and
it's like no he's basically built like
viruses that goes on team teens phones
and uh you know like that that he's very
very good
at it's like what are you optimizing for
right you know if you want to build uh
the next great social network like yeah
K Factor matters in the beginning but
actually what matters more is like what
is the 30 6090 day of retention if you
want to just like go viral and be on
every single you know 14y old's phone in
America then the only thing that matters
is K Factor right both his apps both of
his apps within I don't know a 100 days
of getting acquired or 200 days of
getting acquired you know shut down and
rode off to zero right because they
didn't have retention but the one thing
I would give him a ton of credit for
which I think was really impressive was
a he went back to the well what most
people don't do is they do a space they
become super knowledgeable about it and
they get so jaded and have so much scar
tissue that even though they are the
best equipped person in the world to go
back and build in that space again they
are so turned off they go become a
beginner at something else which I think
is a fine life choice to make from like
a variety of life but like not optimal
from a from like playing the game of
Entrepreneurship the second thing is he
was in the world of I'm going to build a
hit hit social app and the way that a
hit social app works is like get a 100
million plus users and then start to
make money on ads and like raise Venture
Capital do all this when he went back
the second
time he like broke down the fourth wall
of Silicon Valley I was like What if I
don't fund this and what if I just like
charge a little bit of money and like
what if I just make a few million
dollars of profit like every every month
and like I don't know how long it'll
last but I think I can make like
whatever you know like five million
bucks in in the summer that sounds
pretty awesome let me try to do that and
nobody nobody in consumer like the
mobile gaming guys were like yeah of
course like get a bunch of downloads and
then charge like you know a small amount
and see if you can you know make you
know your key metric is arpo but like
the cons the mobile gaming guys don't
build social apps the social apps guys
don't build mobile games the those guys
don't build Enterprise sales like people
very rarely are able to like rethink the
rules of their game and he rethought the
rules of the consumer social game and
was like I'm gonna build a consumer
social app but it's going to have the
monetization of a mobile game and I
think in basically like a six-month span
it made like seven or eight million
dollar in in you know gross revenue with
like you know uh and you know it was
very profitable for him in that period
of time then he sold the thing and the
you know that that is a very impressive
way to like most people can't do that
most people can't rewrite the rules of
the of their industry of their game
there's two things that you made me
think of the first is there's a whole
group of these people who are like
trying to rewrite the rules or think
about this differently one of my
favorite examples and I don't want to
share who it is because I don't know if
they're they're okay with it but um they
created like a ability to make photos in
your Instagram story
blurry and basically you would have to
pay on Apple pay to like unblur the
photo so obviously like all the only fan
girls would put it on their Instagram
story and it'd be like just blurry
enough where people like oh that looks
like something I might really like
looking at and then they they'd pay like
$2 $5 $10 like whatever it was set at
and so you're like bootstrapping off of
these massive audiences these people
already have but it's like a little
feature and they don't raise money for
it it's just like basically how much
money can we generate as quickly as
possible and I mean they make a lot of
money right and so it works so it is
possible speaking of uh folks who go
back to the well do you guys know who
Brad Jacobs is yeah he created like six
billion dollar companies now or
something like that the guy he's the
goat we're I'm trying to I've been
trying to get him on the Pod I've been
trying I I can't I can't he's got a book
coming out he he'll definitely come on
he's got a book coming out so he's 100%
going on I can't get in touch with them
well we'll talk later but he's 100%
going on everyone's podcast because he's
got a book coming out which is like the
best time to get these guys but uh so
about four or five years ago somebody
like almost like uh like a back alley
drug deal was like check out Brad Jacobs
and I was like never heard of him like
who's that got on Wikipedia and
literally for a week and a half like
didn't sleep was just like all over
scouring the internet trying to figure
out like what obscure podcast did this
guy do because he just did it over and
over and over again and what he
essentially does is he just does rollups
like Wayne hazinga is another guy who's
like famous for doing this um and what
Brad did uh is just figure out a
business model figure F out a funding
mechanism start winning and then go
around and tell everyone like hey I'm
going to do the same Playbook and I'm
going to win again and then people gave
out money so explain what he did so uh
one of the things that they did was in
the waste industry which also I think
Wayne heis Zinga had a had a big one as
well um in the waste industry basically
they would go and and where he started
was he didn't go to Major markets he
didn't even go to like what he calls
like secondary markets he basically went
to like Podunk towns and was like I'm
gonna buy the landfill and then once he
bought the landfill he was like okay
there's like seven companies that all
pick trash in the surrounding area and
they bring to this landfill and he would
just like start like sniper off each one
of them he'd buy the first one he'd buy
the second one the third one and
eventually he'd own all seven of the
companies plus the landfill and so he
just did this across the country and he
would roll it all up that one uh was
like I think early 90s was called United
Waste Systems um and so he took that
company public and it ended up being
like a multi-billion dollar outcome he's
done that same thing like six or seven
times now and so you're just like okay
building a billion dollar company's cool
cool building two you're like damn like
you you've got the the Golden Touch if
you do more than five there's like one
of you right I think he's done it with
uh so he did the waste manage management
thing then he did United Rentals which
was like renting uh heavy uh like uh
dump trucks and and porta-potties and
bobcats and things like that then he did
it with EXO Logistics I think which is
currently public XO which is currently
uh a publicly traded company and I think
he did it two or three times I mean he's
done it many many times I think his book
is called how to make a billion dollars
or something like that like it's it's a
pretty it's a pretty baller title like
I'm not coming on my first million um
quite literally beneath
me you want to know something funny
about uh about how he describes himself
he's like you know I'm a career CEO
serial entrepreneur like he has very
much like what you would expect from a
guy who's built multiple billion dollar
companies but if you Google his name uh
you know on LinkedIn how there is like
um a uh like a preview of the site on
LinkedIn it says Brad Jacobs is an
influencer because I think he has like
the influencer like categorization on
LinkedIn and they just like autofill it
but it's like the classic imagine
telling Brad Jacobs like ah you're not
really like a multi-billion dollar
entrepreneur you're just an influencer
he' like blow a gasket yeah that's so
true that's what it says his first top
link on Google Brad Jacobs is an
influencer
period got him like stop disrespecting
that man the reason he's cool is like
okay so he lives grge Connecticut he
wears like a suit and tie most of the
time he's he's he looks like a he looks
like a suit and I'm sure he's very
professional and a wonderful CEO but if
you actually like listen to some of the
things he says he's way more of a uh
he's way more entrepreneurial than like
his picture looks you know what I mean
like he's got that he's got that artist
Vibe a little bit uh the the guy's the
guy's special he's very fascinating but
before his book came out and or is
coming out he's been really under the
radar for how successful he is he's a
really fascinating person person yeah
the the um one of my favorite activities
is like if you're ever reading an
article like uh Bloomberg uh does this a
lot and um actually the financial times
they'll like randomly talk about these
like really wealthy people and I'll just
immediately you know copy paste Google
like hey who is this person and uh
recently I did it and um let me see if I
can find this guy's name real quick
because it was like one of these things
where uh as soon as you go down the
rabbit hole you're like wow this is like
a whole different game
um what is this dude's name oh here you
go Benny
Steins so they call him an Israeli
Tycoon but he like got in a bunch of
trouble and there's like fraud and I
think he maybe even got arrested Etc but
like he's in the Commodities game and
you're like I've never heard of Benny
Steins he sounds like he's built some
massive companies but also in the
Commodities game like sometimes there's
gold in the mine and other times there's
a promise of gold in the mine you know
type thing and so you're just like how
many of these people are out there that
are not on the Internet or not well
known in the like internet Circle and
sure you can go look at the fors 400 you
can go look at like all these lists that
people put together there's way more
people that are completely unknown than
I think known and so it does kind of
reminds you like you don't you only got
to be right once or twice and you can
achieve immense amount of wealth or
success by doing just like the basic
things go buy assets that end up being
valuable if if you Google this guy he
looks like one of these guys that can
like find a pressure point on your neck
that makes you like collapse he looks he
looks he looks very legitimately like a
killer and I researched him as well he
was in the IDF so like he's a trained
military guy and if you Google him he
looks scary he looks like he'll he'll
put you to sleep um what other ideas are
interesting to you at the moment so uh
I'll give you a couple categories
there's one that I uh the best name I
have for it is like persistent Patrol
companies so if you think about one of
the big problems that city states and
the national government's going to have
is like they have to get more money
they're broke right and if you're broke
you either like cut your cost as much as
possible or you go make more money uh
they're not going to cut cost so they
got to make more money um one of the
best examples is in New York City the
congestion tax that's one of the few
taxes that I'm on board with you're on
board okay all right let me explain what
it is first and then and then we can
debate uh the way it works is like I
don't know 9 to5 Monday through Friday
if you drive from like outside of Lower
Manhattan into Lower Manhattan they
charge you like 20 bucks like it's a
pretty large tax every single day so it
only is charged one time but you can
imagine all the cars that are driving
from above 59th Street below 59th Street
between 9: to5 Monday through Friday and
they're getting hit with this $20 tax
it's away for the city to raise more
money get more income um it's called a
congestion tax it's the first one in the
United States but this has been
happening in Europe and other places for
for quite a while so it's not a New
Concept it's just new to America they're
also considering charging uh people like
$1,000 a month or something really high
in order to own a car in the city
there's all kinds of ideas because it
all comes back to this thing like they
need more money right that they're broke
and over the last couple of years in
cities like New York people who were
paying a lot in taxes they left like
there's the infamous story of David
terer he was in New Jersey and he was
responsible for 3% of the state's budget
in the the taxes he personally paid and
he moved to Florida and there's all
these articles that were like the state
of New Jersey is going to go br because
David terer is moving and so I think it
was for like some sort of Family Medical
situation he moved for a couple years
when he moved back the way the story
goes is that he called up the state
treasurer and was like yo you got 120
million coming to you next year like put
into your
budget I'm back baby so like wealthy
people yeah and it's New Jersey it's not
like it's like North Dakota right it's
like the state of New Jersey was
dependent on this guy for material
percentage of uh of their state budget
so wealthy people have been moving so my
idea is like uh well how are they going
to get more Revenue right now a lot of
Revenue is derived from like parking
tickets or like stupid things where they
have humans walking around trying to
like catch people doing things they're
not supposed to be doing so I think
there's going to be an entire rise of
businesses that just use computer vision
to do the same thing like anything that
can be automated will be automated
rather than have humans with their lazy
eyes walking around just have computers
that constantly monitor it so parking
tickets is an easy one Fire Marshals
like how many times have you gone to an
event and it's like Fire Marshall saids
220 people can be here you're like I
think there's a thousand people in this
uh room right now right so like they can
just automate okay you get hit with $500
fine every single time at this event
venue Etc um elevators like you can just
go through this and see over and over
again that computer vision will just
become like the persistent eye it's
scary like I don't like the idea of this
but I do think someone's going to build
this technology and it's not going to be
the government and so we're likely to
see a huge rise of these businesses that
Ed what is pretty like standard
technology at this point to just like
count the number of humans walking into
a building and stay on top of it so that
the government can generate more Revenue
well there's also like in LA don't they
have the Mansion tax right like it's
like oh if you sell a home for more than
$5 million there's just like here's a
new tax and they're like what what do
these people New York has it too live in
small homes like they'll never do it
they'll never downsize like we got them
we can charge literally anything we want
and they're still going to pay it um you
know I I I kind of agree with you that
that getting this Revenue stream is g to
be gon to be important obviously I hate
the idea of the like persistent Patrol
computers basically finding you for for
taking every misstep but um I think
you're the root thing you're talking
about like how do you help governments
make more money is going to be a
business opportunity because you're
right they uh they do need it there's a
competition right now between uh taxes
and tipping like when you go to the
coffee shop there's literally going to
be a competition between is on the bill
if it's itemized does the government get
more money out of the bill or does the
Tipping because we've become this like
tipping Society where somebody like
pours a Cofe they're like that'll be 15%
on top of the bill and so if the
government continues to increase sales
tax like very much these bills are going
to get inflated because it's just
everyone's got more hands in the cookie
jar so Sean New York has a uh Mansions
tax do you want to know what the
threshold is in order to pay it no what
is it all right so keep in mind I think
the average sale of a New York home is
like
800,000 the Mansion tax starts at a
million dollars so basically like you
have a second bedroom
mansion yeah so their mansion tax I I
think it's uh close to 4% it ranges I
think but I think it goes up to 4% so
basically if you purchase a two-bedroom
apartment in New York City you basically
have to say all right here's an
additional 40,000 just for buying or is
it for selling I don't remember which
one but someone pays roughly 2030
$40,000 for a two-bedroom apartment that
and so they have it as well in New York
City it's pretty wild I mean that's like
a $5,000 mortgage payment right like if
you're like hey I don't want to pay s
$8,000 for a two-bedroom I'm gonna in
that buy and I'm gonna have to pay $4500
or $5,000 with eight% interest rates on
my mortgage like a million bucks like
yeah that you're getting hit with the
Mansion tax it's pretty wild but yeah
New York has that New York gets you in
so many different ways it's a very
challenging place to live because of
that you live in New York right
I do live in New York like what will it
take for you to move
basically nothing like at this point I'm
not going to move um I moved uh and I
think that I've come to the realization
that I'm willing to pay for the
experience like yes the taxes are higher
but I feel like the money that I give on
those higher taxes is very much uh in
exchange for the density of New York
City The Experience like uh all of that
and so uh to some degree it's like the
biggest expense I pay every year but
it's because of the quality of life uh
or a specific type of quality of life
that I want and so I've just come to you
know terms with it and like you know
stroke the check every year and compared
to other cities New York does a half
decent job of like making it feel like
you're you're getting what you paid for
you know you you good Parks subway
system whatever but damn it's still
challenging particularly I mean you were
in Florida for a while I'm in Texas at
the moment when I'm thinking about going
in New York I'm like golly this changes
the math a lot the math changes at a
significant amount yeah just close your
eyes and don't
look
yeah all right I got I got one more idea
before we go which is uh AI agents I
don't know uh I sent you guys the link
but this kid I don't know this guy uh
Jacob Greenfield we love this we love
him I don't know him either but he posts
amazing stuff he he immediately is
awesome in my book because he posted
this yesterday and I was thinking like
what we could talk about today um and he
basically used these AI agents which
like that's all I know about them is
they're called AI agents uh but they
like go and do these jobs and so he was
like all right I'm gonna go have an AI
agent that finds opportunities and I'm
going to score the opportunities based
on like how much money could I make and
how difficult would it be to execute and
he basically populated this whole list
and then he's like but haha I'm gonna
create a second AI agent that then goes
and looks at all of the opportunities
that are high earning potential low
difficulty and I'm gonna have them
create a plan on how I could actually
execute to do that thing and then he's
probably going to create like a third AI
agent and be like and then I'm going to
have them carry out the plans from AI
agent number two but it's just like
again yes you have to be technical to be
able to figure some of the stuff out or
or work with technical people but the
world is changing at a very rapid pace
and what we're seeing is everyone was
worried about like the blue collor
worker was gonna get automated away like
damn it sounds like Jacob is automating
away my first million like now all of a
sudden no one has listen to the podcast
they're just going to get a Excel sheet
with like how do I get rich without
doing a lot of work and go do those
opportunities right so so it's cool to
see but um I I do think that there's a
lot of things that people are going to
figure out here uh of just like how to
find better opportunities without having
to spend you know thousands of hours
doing the research this is awesome this
tweet is awesome I'm looking at it now
this is very good they are awesome but
also like like okay I I like like I
think the the it's like one of these
things where like the demo shows you
what's possible but the demo is not like
usable uh in I feel like you know the
same way kind of about VR right now like
uh every I buy the new VR I buy the new
VR every time it comes out and then I
put it on and I'm like holy [__] this is
amazing I can't wait to show five other
people this and then I'm going to put it
on the shelf and not touch it for a year
like but it it soon this will be like
this will be it'll it will solve all the
pain points like um you know you used to
have to be Tethered to a computer now
you don't it used to be where it was
really hot and sweaty in there now it's
not you used to not be able to see the
room when you're there there now you
could see through you could see the room
like they're improving it one step at a
time like for example the things on this
list are
uh you know like clean energy solutions
for shipping innovating fuel Al
Alternatives like okay
yeah sure Money Maker battery that lasts
forever you know
cool I got you pop why isn't real estate
blog on
here not enough money and way too
difficult yeah where is real estate blog
it didn't make the top 30 so I think the
idea of this is really cool but uh you
know in practice like if you if somebody
sat down was like great I'm going to
that thing I'm going to go use that that
thing to make it happen I I don't think
any of it's like usable at this point I
will give you one example that I think
is usable so um I think somebody could
do this right now I think uh you know
somebody who wants to play a different
game could go play this game upwork has
like I don't know three or four billion
dollars of gmv every year of people
basically paying for tasks that get done
in up and uh I'm pretty sure a huge
number of abor tasks and Fiverr tasks
are automatable right now or like maybe
they're not 100% automated but like you
could take that same person use uh you
know use AI uh use use um you you use
technology in order to be like 10x your
output 5x your output so you get just
like better leverage operational
leverage I think if somebody combined
private equity and AI you could go roll
up and buy the top profiles on upwork
and Fiverr so you basically buy the
search juice that these guys have so
that they're going to get the top like
you know logo design you're going to go
get the top jobs because you're the
number one rank because you were there
since 2013 on Fiverr or whatever and I
think you could go buy all of those and
then you could put them all under one
roof and be like that's wild we're gonna
use AI to fulfill a huge number of these
um and you can make a lot of money
because those little properties on top
of Fiverr on top of upwork those are
valuable rental properties essentially
they go get income every month but now
you have a way to get more margin out of
that rental inome so I I think already
you could buy them at a good price
because nobody else is really buying
those but on top of that you could
probably get some more operational
leverage out of it this was the whole
idea that like thaso and other Amazon
aggregators had was they were GNA like
go buy up a bunch of Amazon stores and
uh I know somebody who financed a lot of
them and his thesis was like if you're
the first search result for a very
popular product that is like real estate
and so it's like location location
location like you are the first search
result and so you'll constantly get
traffic obviously there's platform risk
if there's some sort of algorithm change
or whatever but they were able to kind
of model out that risk um the hard part
is like you're dealing in physical Goods
in on Amazon and what you're talking
about is like you're basically just
dealing with software and so there is
100% somebody some obscure place in the
world who is like the best Fiverr logo
designer right now and they are just
like a mid Journey like power user yeah
right and so it's like okay uh I used to
be able to design X number of logos per
month now I can do 100x that and oh you
want to give me feedback no problem I'll
just change the prompt to make it
exactly what you want and I can do it in
you know one 100th at the
time yeah like that sounds awesome to
that person and frankly like that's how
the world should work like you should
pay the same for the result because
you're buying the result not the amount
of work and like that person after
having figured out how to do it is going
to be financially rewarded like we want
that Financial or economic system to be
exactly how business Works do you uh
of all these companies that you're
working on how much time are you
allocating to each one how many
businesses do you have now I don't know
how many but let's just call like around
10 um I I think of it uh kind of a like
a a 2 by2 Matrix to some degree there
are some businesses that are young and
need lots of time and then there are uh
a lot of companies that are older and
don't need as much time the only thing
that changes between those two things is
uh like fires right so it's like if you
look at my day uh it is mostly
distributed to the companies that are
just getting off the ground we're trying
to figure out how to build momentum
we're trying to get to profitability
we're trying to like figure out the
first couple of hires we're trying to
like make sure we got the product
correct like all those types of things
and then uh maybe 20% 15% of my day is
like oh we just lost a big customer or
there's some like fire to put out with
one of the companies that's already
pretty mature but after the first I
don't know six months like the company
works or it doesn't and if it works then
actually I'm probably doing the company
a disservice if I'm like still meddling
in uh the day-to-day like decision-
making and Leadership of the business we
have somebody who runs the company like
they should be the ones to sink or swim
uh and I think they appreciate the
autonomy to just go do it themselves
without you know having me like
micromanage them over their shoulder um
the only thing that I do do is every
week I get a weekly update and frankly
like I read them you know I give a
little bit of feedback here and there
but it's more so for the people who run
the company uh because it forces them
just to write down you know what do we
get done this week and no including
myself ever wants to send an update it's
like we got nothing done so um that's
really the only thing that's like
persistent week in week out regardless
of the uh the the age of the business
how are you balancing the two things of
a like buy versus build so I think Sean
and Andrew Wilkinson they're toying
around the idea of buying parts of
companies or wholly owning owning
companies that they buy as well as focus
of well these one or two things could
have outsides returns I should only do
those yeah um so buying versus build is
like really interesting I've gone back
and forth over the years like we've
bought a couple of businesses not a lot
but but a few um and then we've
obviously built a number of them and you
know there's a sector right now that I'm
looking at um it's in the media space
it's very specific type of audience I
think that it's kind of a unique thing
I'm not usually big on like uh ideas are
valuable this to me is just like we
understand something about an audience
that most other people haven't yet
discovered and so we think that it could
be interesting to go after there's two
players in the market that are well
known in that industry um again it's a a
niche but also like very big and both
players you'd probably have to pay like
over $100 million to buy them in in kind
of total cost and you probably can't buy
a minority stake and so it's like at
this point given our track record I
probably could go try to figure out you
know a bunch of these like big
institutional investors who want to buy
media businesses and like go put it
together it's a lot of work you have to
convince someone to sell it to you you
have to get the terms right integration
like like there's a lot of challenges
but then I'm like dude I think for 100
grand we could create a competitor and
like it's not going to be worth $100
million doll you know within the first
two or three years but like could we
like take a big dent into their
businesses probably so when it's that
skewed I obviously tend to lean towards
building versus buying I think where
it's harder is like hey the business is
worth like $10 million or $5 million and
you're like that's like two years of
progress versus not spending the money
up front and like maybe you get there
that's where I probably lean much more
towards like buying versus building it's
just like it's it's a lower risk and the
deal's easier to get done than trying to
go and you know buy these these huge
things that you know frankly uh there's
only so many people in the world that
are actually good at doing and what
about the focus thing I mean I only do
one thing I I I remember your face
seared in my brain last time you asked
me this and I was like no I don't do a
lot of things I do one thing we provide
capital and distribution to businesses I
think that's I think that's inspiring I
think that Sean and I fall on sides I
actually think Sean I'm slowly buying
into other viewpoints oh [__] I'm trying
to go over to where you're at I'm trying
to focus more Sam has no no hold on a
second This Is A Lie Sam you have
multiple businesses like you're not just
doing one thing although you think of
like I don't know Airbnb short-term
Rental Right like you built that out
like that's a project that you were
working on right at the same time you
were getting Hampton off the ground
right like like there's all these things
where sometimes it's not like okay I'm
going to raise money and go build this
big business it could just be like
projects but you're you're constantly
doing multiple things I call them
Hobbies so I I have a 40-hour week thing
which is actually so I'm disproving my
my own point it's actually podcasting
and Hampton um but so that doesn't
exactly make my point but that's like my
nine to-5 and then like i' I've got like
weekend projects is how I consider it so
meet Sam par he's a podcaster with
weekend
Hobbies podcast influencer content
man producer content producer I think I
think I think we've done a really good
job of rebranding that Creator just
sounds weak for some reason there's a
bunch of people changing their uh X bios
right now they're like just deleting
Creator and putting
producer yeah it's just for some reason
it's a weak that's a weak that's a weak
uh uh word I I don't know what it is but
we do need to Rebrand that well just it
bulks you in with everybody else that's
the problem like uh it's like oh no I
I'm a I'm not like them no no no that
that guy's just unemployed uh there's a
difference you know uh I'm a different
thing I need to have a new name I met a
guy who uh he was one of the early hires
at paler and uh he he essentially like I
don't know he didn't tell me this but
like I think he was like basically the
COO right or whatever in the early days
and he was like yeah one of the cool
things about the culture is like you
kind of like jointly with your boss made
up your title and so his was like Risk
identifier and
Destroyer
right and it's just like man names do
matter like what does that guy do I want
to go work at the company where like
that could be my title and it's very
clear inside the organization what the
president does at different companies
may be different but the guy whose title
is like Risk identifier and Destroyer is
100% focused on risk and so uh same
thing like content creator like maybe
it's the wrong name and just change the
name and then all of a sudden everyone's
really excited about it chamath has a
good story about this he says when he
was at Facebook they were trying to hire
like you know some PhD level um you know
math and stats guy and they were like
cool like you can come be a data analyst
he's like I don't want to be a data
analyst I'm gonna go get my PhD instead
he's like I don't know did I say data
anal data scientist where you have a new
field called data science and you're one
of the first to be a data scientist on
Earth and he's like yeah I invented the
tag data science and then now it's like
you know a whole like prestigious job
title in Silicon Valley is is data
science is that story true that's that's
a that's a hard story to believe is you
think that's true uh yeah I believe it I
don't know I have no reason not to
believe it
[Laughter]
I did I I love those guys so much on the
Allin podcast but I was laughing uh that
people were giving them [__] about the
uh using scare muchi as a measuring
stick you guys see this yeah no what's
that like scare scare mcci was the white
house uh communications director for 11
days I think right I mean like the
infamous photo he's got the sunglasses
on with the finger guns like probably
one of the the greatest stints in the
White House of all time um and uh so
people always tweet at scaramucci like
when some you know like EMT Shear was
the CEO of open AI for like 48 hours
they're like hey how many scaramucci did
he last and scaramucci were like
calculated like you know point2 or
whatever um and so the Allin guys they
had been saying it for a while and they
were like yeah we invented that they
were like on Twitter they're like give
us credit if you're gonna use it and uh
and
then the the internet loves to hate on
those guys if you're not like the tech
industry so they were like waiting for
them to say something and of course they
all started pulling up like articles and
whatever and like man this is like PEAK
Internet right is like somebody wants
credit for a term that no one's really
clear where it came from and then a
bunch of people who don't like that
person is wants to critique them and
yell and scream and like go do a bunch
of work uh to disprove them I was like
we are all wasting our time we should
just get off the internet like go do
productive things but uh it's kind of
like when I when I say MFM uh we get
credit for making Andrew huberman and
Brian Johnson famous uh the longevity
guy according to us yeah you're welcome
world I actually think that Kim
Kardashian's famous because of you guys
didn't one of you tweet about her early
on yeah it's like you ever heard of Rob
dierck first one to watch her work I
think uh
yeah um P thanks for doing this man we
love hanging out with you absolutely I
appreciate you guys very much uh can I
plug one thing before I leave yeah yeah
we have a job board it's called dream
startup job.com uh used to be called
poomp crypto jobs it was just crypto
we've now expanded it to be crypto and
everything else uh We've helped three
three people a day on average for now
over two years get a new job um and so
there's 10,000 open roles on there if
you want to get a job at your dream
startup you should go to dream startup
job.com and uh and check it out all
right appreciate it looks good uh I I I
remember what it used to be I think this
is a this is a smart move well we'll
figure it out I appreciate you fellas
good to see you man that's the
[Music]
pod
no